meet Rosalie for souza
a grad student in Nancy kanwisher slab
she donated her brain to this project
well sorta
here's a picture of roses brain taken at
the Martinez Imaging Center here at MIT
now here it is again cut into 23
vertical and 4 horizontal slices thanks
to Ben Martel a postdoc in Alan jasnoch
lab he agreed to donate his time a lot
of his time to this project how long is
this process
longer than I hoped but less than I
steer been used a laser cutter at MIT s
hobby shop to carve roses brain slices
into eight-foot sheets of plywood but
that was just the beginning we needed to
paint all sixty of roses brain slices on
both sides so we enlisted the help of
MIT s brain and cognitive scientists
community we bribed them with pizza and
they came staff postdocs grad students
and even faculty
the wet and cold spring weather warped
the brain slices making the intersecting
pieces a little difficult to assemble it
wasn't pretty but we got it done to
activate the brain we called in the
experts
professor Rebecca Saxe analyzed roses
brain and identified regions that become
active when she does things like talk
reach or think about what another person
is thinking now we were ready for the
big time there was only one problem
getting the 200-pound top-heavy brain
out of building 46 was a bit
nerve-racking we lost an eyeball while
crossing Vassar Street we turned a few
heads on Mass Ave and we even lost joy
before the parade begins but we
persevered we wowed the crowd we
revealed the mind inside and we stunned
the judges in short we did what we came
to do
you